the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
our lecture today concerns mathematical
induction which roughly speaking is a
technique that one uses to prove
something when one already has a pretty
good suspicion as to what the right
answer is now rather than to
philosophize about this too long let's
stare right into a problem and see in
action just what the concept means
recall that in an earlier lecture we
have proven that the limit of a sum is
equal to the sum of the limits provided
of course that there are only two terms
in the sum that is if we have two
functions F 1 and F 2 the limit of F 1
of X plus F 2 of X as X approaches a is
the limit of F 1 of X as X approaches a
plus the limit of F 2 of X as X
approaches a the question now is how
about the limit as X approaches a of F 1
of X plus F 2 of X plus F 3 of X now to
tackle a problem like this we do what is
so often done in any mathematical
logical procedure we try to reduce an
unfamiliar problem to a familiar problem
which has already been solved let's see
what I mean by that if this had been
only two terms in here that we were
adding we would have known how to handle
this problem so what we observe is that
since the sum of two functions is again
a function we can assume that our
expression is written this way now you
see we've reduced our problem to the sum
of two functions namely F 1 of X plus F
2 of X being one of our functions F 3 of
X being another of our functions we know
now what that the limit of a sum is the
sum of the limits if we have two
functions you see this is what the limit
F 1 of X plus F 2 of X you see plus the
limit as X approaches a F 3 of X but now
look what's in this expression over here
this is now what the limit of the sum
our two functions and you see we know
that the limit of a sum is the sum of
the limits is true if we have only two
functions so from here we get the
here and from here we can say what this
is the limit X approaches a f1 of X plus
the limit as X approaches a f2 of X plus
the limit as X approaches a f3 of X in
other words what we have shown is that
the limit of a sum equals the sum of the
limits is true not just for the sum of
two functions but for the sum of three
as well and more importantly the truth
for three-hinged directly on the truth
for two in other words it wasn't just
that we proved that the formula was true
for the sum of three functions we proved
it on the assumption that it was already
true for the sum of two functions and by
the way notice how we may now begin to
suspect that this idea generalizes for
example let's take a look over here
suppose I now said how about the limit
as X approaches a and we'll now take the
sum of four functions f1 of X plus f2 of
X plus F 3 of X plus f4 of X see what
about something like that and again we
argue the same way as we did before we
say you know if we only had two
functions in here and let's give this to
him to do this see we do know that the
limit of the sum is the sum of the
limits if we have only two functions you
see now I could write this as what it's
the limit of the first one as X
approaches a but what is the first one
the first one is the function f1 of X
plus f2 of X plus F 3 of X plus the
limit of the second the second now you
see is f sub 4 of X as X approaches a
now you see our previous case told us
what that the limit of a sum is equal to
the sum of the limits if you have the
sum of 3 functions that's exactly what
we have over here and now you see we can
say what ah this is the limit of the
first
as X approaches a plus the limit of the
second as X approaches a plus the limit
of the third as X approaches a plus the
limit of the fourth as X approaches a in
other words what have we done now we've
shown that knowing that the limit of a
sum is the sum of the limits was true
for a sum of two functions and of three
functions we've shown inescapably that
the same result holds for the sum of
four functions let's take a little
breather here and make a few asides I
think sometimes when one starts to work
too much with mathematical symbolism we
lose track of the fact that things are
not quite as difficult as they might
otherwise have seemed you see for one
thing my claim is that we have already
tackled this problem as recently as 1st
grade arithmetic namely we learned what
we learned tables remember the addition
tables you learned how to add two
numbers all of the sudden somebody says
what is the sum of 1 2 3 & 4 what is
this number and what we said was lookit
we'll just add these two at a time 1
plus 2 is a number which is 3 3 plus 3
is a number namely 6 & 6 plus 4 is a
number 10 in other words we essentially
did what we add the first to the second
then we added the sum of the first two
to the third the sum of the first 3 to
the fourth and that was how we did this
of course what we assumed in doing this
was that the sum of two numbers was
again a number up above we assumed that
the sum of two functions was a function
and this is not quite as trivial as it
might otherwise have seen namely look at
if you add two odd numbers do you get
right things when you combine like
things the sum of two odd numbers is
always even you see you can say let's
replace the sum of two odd numbers by
another odd number you can say it but it
would be wrong on the other hand another
example how about subtraction
that's a nice operation if you subtract
a positive number from a positive number
are you guaranteed that the result will
be positive well for example what about
three less five the answer would be
negative - positive - positive can very
well be negative so we must be sure what
that when we combine like objects we get
like objects and another thing that we
assumed was that our answer did not
depend upon voice inflection now what
does that mean
let me show you something over here look
at the expression 12 divided by 6
divided by 2 if you read this as if it
said 12 divided by 6 divided by 2 the
answer is 1 on the other hand if you
read the same thing as if it said 12
divided by 6 divided by 2 the answer is
what 12 divided by 3 which is 4 in other
words division depends on voice
inflection
whereas addition doesn't and I simply
point out these decides to show you that
as we go through advanced mathematical
analysis we are always making use of the
same assumptions that we were making
when we dealt with more simple things
and I think this is the healthiest way
of seeing how our subject develops we
will lead from things that we already
know into generalizations that are less
familiar to us at any rate let's now
return to our main theme of mathematical
induction and try to summarize what's
happened so far we are working with a
certain conjecture let's call it the
conjecture is that the limit of a sum is
the sum of the limits we know that the
conjecture was true for two terms we
proved that once it was true for two
terms it was true for three terms we
then prove it if it was true for three
terms it was true for four terms and now
if we have any imagination at all we
might become suspicious and say you know
I think if it's true in general for any
terms it's going to be true for n plus 1
terms and that brings us to our next
stage in our mathematical induction
namely suppose the limit of a sum is
equal to the sum of the limits in the
case that there are n terms in our sum
what can we conclude about the limit of
the sum in the case of n plus 1 terms
and without going through the proof here
we'll do these things in our
supplementary notes in our learning
exercises but here I just want to focus
our attention on what the main theme is
what we say is look at since we can add
without worrying about voice inflection
why don't we throw in a pair of braces
here thus reducing our problem to the
limit of the sum when we are adding but
two functions use the theorem there and
now given the limit of the sum of the N
functions we know that that's the limit
of the sum and now it appears that the
truth for n is going to imply the truth
for n plus 1 now of course there may be
other problems that work structurally
this way other than the limit of a sum
equals the sum of the limits so let's
generalize that result and the
generalization is what is known as
mathematical induction what mathematical
induction says is this let's suppose we
have a conjecture
now how we get the conjecture is
something we'll talk about in a while
but let's suppose we have the conjecture
well to try to show the conjecture is
true all the time we had better be sure
it's true at least some times so we say
okay let's show that the conjecture is
true for N equals 1 that's just a simple
verification we show it it's true for N
equals 1 then we say okay next prove
that the truth for N equals K implies
the truth for N equals K plus 1 in other
words we're not saying that it's true
for K all we're saying is that if it's
true for K if it's true for K the truth
for N equals K implies the truth for N
equals K plus 1 then if that's true our
conjecture is true for all whole numbers
why is that
well let's take a look informally here
we know let's suppose
both of these conditions are obeyed we
know the conjecture is true when N
equals 1 now take K to be 1 since it's
true for 1 this part tells us it's going
to be true for 1 more than 1 which is 2
now that the conjecture is true for 2
this says what it's going to be true for
3 and knowing that it's true for 3 this
will say it's true for 4 and now I'll
loosely use the word etc and come back
and reinforce that as we go along I
think now perhaps the best thing to do
is to look at the second example you see
what we did first of all was we use an
example to lead into what the definition
would be now that we have the definition
let's proceed directly to use it let me
give you a conjecture the conjecture
which I have in mind is that the sum of
the first n positive numbers and it's an
interesting formula it's the last number
multiplied by one more than the last
number divided by 2
well let's just see if that's true at
all for a while look at 1 plus well if n
is 1 if n is 1 the right-hand side here
the left-hand side here is 1 and 1 times
2 divided by 2 is also 1 if n is 2 the
sum of the first two numbers here is
what 1 plus 2 is 3 on the other hand 2
times 3 divided by 2 is also 3 so at
least our conjecture is true for N
equals 1 and N equals 2 what does
mathematical induction say let's take a
look again now you see we show that the
conjecture was true for N equals 1 and
for good measure we also show that was
true for N equals 2 so we can check this
off we've done that now what do we do we
assume the conjecture is true for N
equals K that means what what this
replace n by K
we're assuming that this is true from
the truth of this what must we do next
well what we must do next is investigate
what happens if you add what not K
numbers but K + 1 C in other words what
happens when you replace M by K + 1 now
watch how we do this the same thing that
we did in theory before we say look at
we already know how to handle this
amount we're told that that's going to
be K times k plus 1 over 2 so let's
rewrite this in this way now we can
replace the bracketed expression by K
times k plus 1 over 2 we add on of
course k plus 1 because that's the last
term that's over here now we factor out
k plus 1 from this factor here that
leaves us with what K over 2 plus 1 and
this in turn says what that the sum of
the first K plus 1 numbers is k plus 1
times k plus 2 over 2 and notice that
that's exactly what the conjecture
should say when n equals k plus 1 namely
what the sum of the first and numbers no
matter how many you have is what the
last number times 1 more than the last
number divided by 2 the sum of the first
K plus 1 numbers is what it's k plus 1
the last 1 times k plus 2 which is 1
more than the last one divided by 2 and
now what we've done is we have verified
the second part of our mathematical
induction
setup namely if we go back to our basic
definition over here we have to show
what prove that the truth for N equals K
implies the truth for N equals K plus 1
which is exactly what we did and while
you're thinking about that let's take a
break for a few more asides which I
think may cement down this idea a little
bit more strongly I mentioned before
that induction is something that one
uses when one already
has a suspicion as to what the right
answer is I don't know how this grabs
you but my own particular feeling is
that you do not look at the sum of the
first n numbers and say aha it's the
last one times one more than the last
one / - you see that's the nice thing
about textbook problems when they give
you a problem on induction and they say
prove this conjecture notice that
they've already given you a tremendous
hint namely they've told you what the
conjecture is you see in the textbook of
real life one usually has to find out
what the conjecture is for oneself in
fact in the form of a rather interesting
aside there is a very interesting
mathematical anecdote connected with
this particular problem it's an anecdote
attributed to the mathematician Gauss
who when he was a young chap was a
discipline problem in school and the
story is that his his teacher his
teacher as a punishment asked him to add
the first hundred numbers and Gauss
wrote down the answer very very rapidly
and what he did was he didn't add these
all up when he observed was what the
first one plus the last one add up to
101 the second plus the next to the last
added up to 101 you see and each pair
going in this way add up to 101 and how
many pairs were there altogether why
there were 100 numbers so there were 50
pairs in other words there were one a
hundred divided by two pairs each pair
adding up to 101 and now notice the
recipe a hundred namely the last number
times one more than the last number 101
divided by 2 by the way in the exercises
on this assignment we have another
problem and that is if you think this
one was already cumbersome try guessing
what the recipe for this one is what is
the sum of the first n squares in other
words not 1 + 2 + 3 etc but 1 squared
plus 2 squared + 3 squared etc I'll give
you the answer but try to think for a
while as to how likely it is that you
would have conjectured this in the first
place
turns out to be n times n plus 1 times 2
n plus 1 over 6 you see the reason I
bring this out is that I call this a
contrived example it is not the case
where the mathematician would most
likely have invented mathematical
induction the case where he would have
invented mathematical induction is the
case that we did earlier for example
where we talked about the limit of a sum
being the sum of the limits you can
actually see what's happening how the
truth FET K implies the truth for K plus
1 and by the way let me make one more
aside here that I forgot to mention
earlier in our definition of
mathematical induction we said show the
conjecture is true for N equals 1 this
was quite hypocritical because the very
first example that I picked didn't even
start until n was 2 we talked about the
limit of a sum being the sum of the
limits and the smallest sum we talked
about was the sum of two terms the point
that I wanted to mention is for example
suppose that the first number you can
prove the conjecture for is for example
N equals 7 I don't know why I pick 7 I
have to pick something let's just call
it N equals 7 suppose I can also show
that if the conjecture is true for K
it's true for K plus 1 then you see what
I can conclude is up I can conclude that
it's true for N greater than or equal to
7 namely if it's true for 7 this says it
will be true for 1 more than 7 which is
8 if it's true for 8 this says it would
be true for 9 if it's true for 9 this
says will be true for 10 etc and we go
on this way now again this may be a very
naive way of looking at it but I always
look at mathematical induction as a
bunch of Toy Soldiers stacked up in a
line in such a way that if any one of
the Toy Soldiers falls down he knocks
down the one that's immediately behind
them ok
you see what I'm driving out here if the
first Falls and by the way that's a big
if if the first Falls he knocks down the
second the second falling knocks down
the third the third falling knocks down
the fourth the fourth falling down
knocks down the fifth etc notice that if
the first one doesn't fall none of them
fall or for that matter going back to my
previous
analogy if the seventh one is the first
one that falls all the ones behind him
fall down now be very careful
mathematical induction doesn't say the
first 50 fall down are the first hundred
fall down it says they all have to fall
down for example his a case where
several fall down but all of a sudden
one isn't knocked down by the one in
front of them in other words what
mathematical induction really involves
is the idea not just that something is
true but that it's true because the
previous one was true you see for
example is it possible that all of the
soldiers fall down even though the one
in front didn't knock the other guy down
I mean it's possible all of these go
down but for different reasons
mathematical induction says much more
than that mathematical induction says
yes they all go down
but each goes down because of the one
before and by the way one more little
aside notice that in our analog we
assumed that there was a next one
whatever you say well we mean you
assumed it was the next one obviously
there has to be a next one but the
concept of next depends on whole numbers
for example when you deal with fractions
there is no next one let me show you
what I mean by that let's talk about the
real numbers in general on the number
line hit zero what is the first fraction
the first real number I don't care what
you call it
what is the first number which is
greater than zero what is the first
number which is greater than zero and
the answer is there is none because
whichever one you pick call it R but R
stands for the first number which you
think is bigger than zero
okay how about R over 2 R over 2 is
still bigger than zero but our over 2 is
less than R in other words between given
any number you pick that's bigger than
zero you can fit in another one so there
is no number which is immediately next
to zero in other words as a caution
notice that mathematical induction is
use when we're dealing with a whole
number of objects
now let's emphasize some of these little
asides from a more specific point of
view let me first of all give you an
example in which something is true for a
whole bunch of numbers but all of a
sudden isn't true in general
now how anybody ever stumbled across the
example I'm going to give you next I
have no idea but I find it's a very
interesting concept let's look at this
let's write down the following function
P of n where n is any positive whole
number will be defined to be N squared
minus n plus 41 for example P of 1 will
be 1 squared minus 1 plus 41 which
happens to be 41 41 happens to be a
prime number a number which has no
factors other than itself and one let's
try 2 in here 2 squared minus 2 plus 41
is 43 also a prime number let's try 3 in
here 3 squared is 9 minus 3 is 6 plus 41
is 47 also a prime number the amazing
thing is that as you go all the way
through to 40 you get nothing but prime
numbers and you say ah it's right so far
it must be right all the time and this
is wishful thinking this is like the man
who wants to count the deck of cards to
see if the cards are all there and he
says 1 2 3 4 5 well so far so good they
must all be here it's like falling off
the Empire State Building and halfway
down somebody says how you're doing you
say so far so good
now we're in a little bit of trouble
here because as soon as we pick em to be
41 watch what happens here this becomes
41 squared minus 41 plus 41 and this is
41 squared which obviously is not a
prime its 41 times 41 and here's an
interesting example where a certain
formula generates nothing but primes for
the first for the integers but fails on
the 41st integer why did this happen
because evidently the fact that this was
a prime in no way dependent structure
only on the fact that this one was a
prime there is our mathematical
induction again that not only must the
conjecture be true but it must follow
inescapably
from the case before if you'd like a
more fascinating realistic example it's
something that we call the unique
factorization theorem of elementary
number theory this says that every
positive whole number greater than one
can be factored uniquely into a product
of primes unique up to the order in
which you write them fruits for example
2 is already a prime it's 2 3 is already
a prime 3 4 can be factored as 2 times 2
5 can be factored as well it's already a
prime it's 5 6 can be written as what 2
times 3 7 can be written of course as 7
it's already a prime 8 is 2 times 2
times 2 9 is 3 times 3 10 is 2 times 5
and 11 is already a prime well this
doesn't prove anything I'm just trying
to demonstrate what the theorem says the
interesting thing is do you notice how n
plus 1 factors I don't know what phrase
to use here but let's call it
considerably different than n in other
words look at what happened to 10 when I
added one on to it its factored into 2
times 5 I add 1 onto it and all of a
sudden the factorization properties
change let me give you an example look
at 5959 happens to be a prime look at
6161
also happens to be a prime by the way
for those of you who are number theory
buffs these are called twin primes
consecutive odd numbers which are both
prime are called twin primes by the way
2 is the only even prime of course
because if a number is greater than 2 it
and it's even it's divisible by 2 so 2
is the only even prime twin primes are
what consecutive odd numbers both of
which are primes
so 59 and 61 are a pair of twin primes
one might intuitively suspect therefore
that the number between them must be
sort of a crime to our
whatever that means obviously it can't
be a-prime because in between them comes
60 which is in particular an even number
but look at all the nice factors that 60
has 60 is what it's one more than 59 one
less than 61 but look at how difference
it factors in fact a pseudo induction
type thing is look at the factors of 60
one two three four five six we say what
seven experimental error no no but this
is not induction by the way notice the
fact that one two three four five and
six are all factors of 60 does not mean
that seven is going to be a factor of 60
we do not say just because it works so
far it's going to keep working and I'm
not going to belabor this point anymore
suffice it to say that look at how
differently sixty factors compared to
the number that came just before it and
the number that came just after it in
other words assuming that the unique
factorization theorem is true the truth
for n plus one somehow or other has
nothing to do with the truth for N and
you see this is again another weakness
of what's called induction well so
that's a weakness of induction the point
that I'm making is why shouldn't
induction have some weaknesses after all
if we could solve every problem what we
would do is have a calculus book that
was three pages long would be called the
principle of mathematical induction when
we solve that problem by induction
everything else would be done no there
are problems that do not lend themselves
to induction in summary induction is a
particularly effective technique which
one uses to prove that something is true
for all whole numbers provided that one
has a suspicion that this thing is true
in the first place and secondly that
even if the suspicion is true the truth
for the n plus first case follows
inescapably from the truth for the empty
case at any rate this completes our
lecture for today and until next time
goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate